godzilla
is just amazing we have probably done
almost every kind of video there is to
do about the g-man
but in this video we will be discussing
about a particular iconic feature of his
his roar what are its origins how
powerful it is
how loud it is and also its comparison
with other loud sounds
generated by things such as rockets
howitzers
and animals we shall start however with
a brief introduction
into the origin of the roar and then
focus onto monsterverse godzilla
funny thing about it godzilla's original
1954 roar was created by composer akira
ifukube
who dragged a resin-coated leather glove
along the loosened strings
of a double bass one of toho's
electrical engineers made a simplistic
amplifying device some time before
the production of king of the monsters
got on the way it was just a box that
had several coils connected to an
amplifier
and a speaker inside it when you struck
it the coils would vibrate and a loud
shocking sound would be created
similar to that of godzilla's so how
loud is godzilla's roar
it is officially stated to be 174
decibels in power
and can be heard three miles away seems
powerful and loud enough
actually the decibel range of his roar
and how far he can be heard
doesn't really add up okay let's start
with basics
decibel is a unit used to measure the
intensity of a sound
or the power level of an electrical
signal normal conversation
is about 60 decibels a lawn mower is
about 90 decibels
a loud rock concert is about 120
decibels
a gunshot point blank is around 140
decibels
and any continual exposure to decibel's
levels of above
140 can cause immediate hearing damage
so imagine if 140 decibels can cause or
impair human hearing
then what would 174 do again that is the
intensity of his roar
it would be strong enough to blow the
glass of buildings and the eardrums and
lungs of anyone near him would explode
so the humans standing close by to him
anywhere from his first appearance in
hawaii
to the battle in san francisco or boston
they would all be pulverized honestly
it's just a big plot hole
that the main characters and all these
human soldiers could still make
phone calls after being in the vicinity
of godzilla when he was roaring
so if we were to compare his intensity
with other animals
then the big cats would be a good
reference point so a lion or a tiger can
roar as loud as 114 decibels
and the lions roar can be heard five
miles away and the lion
has the loudest roar of all the big cats
so what about other animals then
the blue whale the largest animal on
earth can produce a loud whistling coal
that can reach up to 188 decibels
these calls can travel up to 500 miles
or 800 kilometers
underwater now we come back to the
g-man's roar
it was officially stated that he can be
heard from three miles away
or nearly five kilometers sounds weak or
rather lazily estimated by legendary
pitchers
if a line with levels of magnitudes
lower can be heard 5
miles or 8 kilometers away then why is a
400 foot tall titan rather a super
species
could only be heard from five kilometers
away that's three kilometers distance
that's unacceptable and we mind you will
bring to you guys the actual audible
range
of godzilla's roar and for that we will
have to dive into a little bit of
acoustic science
see if a point source or rather a source
of sound in a free field produces a
sound level
of 90 decibels at a distance of 1 meter
then the sound pressure level would
decrease to 84 decibels
at 2 meters and 78 decibels at 4 meters
and so forth
this principle holds true regardless of
the units used to measure distance
in other words it decreases by less than
6 decibels each time the distance of the
sound source doubles
you can explore numerically to confirm
that doubling the distance drops the
intensity by about 6 decibels
and at 10 times the distance will drop
the intensity by 20 decibels
now let's take things that we have
confirmed earlier the blue whale's
whistling can reach decibels of up to
188
and a range of up to 500 miles
underwater so if we minus 12 decibels
then we would have 176
which was roughly the intensity of the
g-man's roar
then we would also have to half the
distance two times as well
bringing the range of his roar
underwater up to 125 miles
or 200 kilometers but that is underwater
and so he wouldn't
actually be able to roar but if we take
into account something that is very loud
in normal air or free feel
then let us look into the saturn v
rocket the saturn v generated sound
level of up to 200 decibels
you could theoretically hear the saturn
v from 373 miles or 600 kilometers away
therefore we have to subtract 6 decibels
four times
and therefore reduce the range by half
four successive times
which would bring 37 kilometers as the
result
so yes in a free field or in land that
is how far godzilla's roar can be heard
which will also correspond to sounds of
artillery fire
being heard more than 50 kilometers away
and their intensity is about 180
decibels or so
however this would include the
ultrasonic alpha calls of the titanic
super species
which have the ability to travel and be
heard by other titans
for thousands of miles away but then
that is the topic for another video
so anyway do like share and subscribe
for more related content on kaiju
monsters and more
remember godzilla can be heard from 37
kilometers away